l'inversion de la courbe de taux vous
avez possiblement entendu parler de ça
cet été un signal d'une possible
récession aux états unis en 2020 ou 2021
avec nous pour en parler vincent delisle
kosheib déplacement chez hexavest
bonsoir soit inversion de la courbe de
taux c'est vraiment l'expression qui a
été beaucoup entendu je sais pas si tout
le monde en a parlé autour des barques
barbecue cet été mais c'est apparu comme
étant un signal réel de récession oui
mais historiquement on regarde les dix
dernières récessions aux états unis
certains indicateurs précurseurs qui
arrive avant la récession qui ont eu
vraiment un bon bilan et l'inversion des
courbes de rendement est un des
indicateurs qui ait eu le plus de succès
alors ça faisait quelques années pour
être franc qu'on lui qu'on le suivait
parce qu'en 2006 2007 ça avait été une
lumière rouge qui s'était allumé alors
il ya beaucoup d'emphase beaucoup
d'attention et depuis qu'elle s'est
inversée je vous dirais que on en parle
on en parle peut-être trop mais c'était
très médiatique alors tout cas il faut
en parler puis l'expliqué aussi on va
regarder un graphique qui vous allez
nous expliquer par la même occasion ce
que ça veut dire l'inversion des courbes
de taux
oui le graphique qu'on à l'écran la
ligne illustre la différence entre les
taux d'intérêt long terme et le taux
d'intérêt court terme les gouvernements
prête sur le marché lorsque la ligne
jaune est au dessus de zéro ça veut dire
que les taux d'intérêt long terme sont
plus élevés que les taux d'intérêt court
terme ok les bâtonnets bleus sont les
récessions alors quand ça va bien quand
l'économie rebondit
normalement les taux à long terme sont
plus élevés que les taux court terme
vers la fin des cycles ici la ligne est
en dessous de zéro est censé en 2007
alors ça c'est 2007 ici c'est 2001 là
c'est au début des années 90 ici c'est
c'est aujourd'hui à l'arc toujours fait
moi c'est l'an dernier la réserve
fédérale américaine a grimpé ses taux
d'intérêt s'en est suivie une crainte
sur le marché que ces hausses de taux
d'intérêt la allait ralentir l'économie
ajoutez à cela les tensions commerciales
les tweets du président trump ont amené
dans les dernières semaines derniers
mois une inversion de la courbe alors
pratico pratique ce que ça veut dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui si vous regardez
tout l'intérêt échéance trois mois aux
etats unis ils sont plus élevés que les
taux d'intérêt
chez ans dix ans alors pour un
investisseur le signal que ça envoie
c'est que mon argent je veux un taux
d'intérêt court terme la confiance en
l'avenir
elle n'est plus là donc c'est une mesure
de sentiments très très forte c'est un
signal très fort qui nous dit y'a pas
d'appétit pour le risque sur le marché
parce qu'on craint un ralentissement de
l'économie des troubles des incertitudes
qui sont alimentés en bonne partie en ce
moment par les tensions commerciales
absolument parce qu'on craint un
ralentissement économique qui va faire
en sorte que les taux de la banque
centrale aujourd'hui vont devoir être
baissé alors on se dit les taux vont
être plus bas et n'oublions pas que le
prix les obligations fluctue inversement
aux taux d'intérêt donc quand les taux
d'intérêt baissent le cri de
l'obligation montant quelqu'un qui
achète une obligation aujourd'hui se dit
probablement que je peux l'acheter à un
meilleur prix
plus tard parce que j'achète des
obligations parce que c'est un actif
jugé sécuritaire des obligations
gouvernementales j'en achète j'en achète
j'en achète
je suis prêt à accepter un rendement
moindre absolument et aujourd'hui on
essaie de rendement moindre sur les
échéances à plus long terme ce qui est
très important pour le cycle économique
aussi c'est le cycle des crédits alors
les banques se financent est prête à
long terme leur actuellement sont par
exemple du canada le taux de la banque
du canada est à un point 75% alors une
banque x emprunte un important des 15 %
se retourne vous le prête à vous et à
moi il ya un an
on prêtait sur échéance 5 10 ans à un
taux de 2 points 50% aujourd'hui ce taux
10 ans au canada et l'étape à 1.20 donc
c'est moins intéressant pour la banque
de prêter cédé presque pas du tout
intéressant donc perte de d'appétit pour
le risque sentiment des primes et des
investisseurs et les banques qui sont un
moteur important dans cette économiques
sont moins enthousiastes à prêter et
quand on regarde le secteur
manufacturier ce qu'on appelle l' indice
des des d'achat c'est natacha dans le
secteur manufacturier on voit que la
confiance ralenti sensiblement
absolument rien c'est que c'est arrivé
par le passé les leçons le secteur
manufacturier celui qui est le plus
touché actuellement donc tous les
querelles commerciales touche
principalement les chaînes de montage en
est
les chaînes de montage aux états unis ce
conte à l'écran si la ligne
cette année dix qui s'appelle i sm c'est
un sondage à tous les mois wade
directeur d'entreprise était une erreur
on leur demande pensez vous que ça va
s'améliorer ou non dans les prochains
mois une mesure au dessus de 50 est un
signal positif
une mesure qui s'approche de 50 est un
signal neutre donc on voit bien de la
crise là en 2008 absolue marc depuydt de
confiance il ya beaucoup de focus sur
cette crise de 2008 là mais je m'en
voudrais pas vous rappeler que ça arrive
des ralentissements il y en a eu en
2012-2013 récession européenne y en a eu
deux trois ans lorsque le prix du
pétrole a baissé donc chaque
ralentissement ne devient pas une
récession majeure mais actuellement de
la courbe de rendement qui est inversé
les manufacturiers américains qui sont
inquiets en grande partie à cause de la
querelle commerciale alors s'amène et
climat d'incertitude qui je vous dirais
aussi reflète est reflétée par l'extrême
volatilité qu'on a sur les marchés donc
est ce que vous direz que les marchés
nous annonce qu'on s'en va en récession
s'attendent prévoit une récession est ce
qu'il est acquis conservant récession
dont il n'est pas acquis du tout cas
savoir et ce sont les risques de
récession les probabilités de récession
sont aussi aux environs de 20 à 30%
actuellement en 2001 pour 2010 pour les
12 prochains mois
on a commencé à l'introduction à parler
de la courbe de rendement qui a été
fortement médiatisée les marchés
craignent un ralentissement sévère et
subi seulement ce qu'on voyait c'est que
les récessions tendait à surprendre de
marché en ce moment le marché craint
davantage le ralentissement de plus
préemptif préventif convoi comme
réaction sur les marchés comme un film
au ralenti
et comme un tempo ralenti et qui est
alimenté par le président américain est
risible
absolument voilà merci vous couvrir de
lise landry
en tout cas la récession c'est vraiment
le premier sujet que je vous propose
dans le cadre d'un tout nouveau balado
j'aurai le plaisir de présenter dès le 5
septembre questions d'intérêt le balado
économique de radio canada avec vincent
delisle
on n'ira plus en profondeur sur les
possibilités de récession ce soit sur
l'application mobile de radio canada